you've probably heard about anthos
Google clouds application platform for
modern enterprise environments if you
want a chance to try anthos for yourself
the good news is now you can I'm going
to show you exactly how easy it is to
get started exploring anthos using the
Antho sample deployment when we're done
go ahead and follow the link to our
online tutorial launch your own sample
deployment and try out anthos for
yourself we have a sample application an
online store that's an example of a
modern micro services application that
will run in the multi cluster kubernetes
environment created by our deployment
everything i show you and more is
published as a tutorial and our online
Doc's this is where you want to go to
get started what I'm going to show you
will be running on a Google cloud but
keep in mind that anthis is here to help
you build and manage your modern
application workloads running where your
enterprise needs them whether that's on
Google cloud multi cloud or in hybrid
environments the sample deployment has
two clusters for hosting copies of our
application services there's also a
config repo that we'll use for
maintaining all configuration under
version control we'll access cloud shell
from a browser to edit policies in a
clone of the config repo we'll push are
committed changes to the upstream
configure Evo and then they will get
automatically synchronized across both
clusters at those config management
let's dive right in we need a project
for the services and resources that the
anthro sample deployment or user create
for this tour we'll start with the new
one and then let's navigate to the
anthos dashboard
we'll need to enable the Athos API and
then again back at the dashboard we can
now launch the deployment you can click
through I accept any defaults after
around 10 minutes everything will be
deployed configured and running after
the deployment is finished let's go back
to the Atlas dashboard to explore the
infrastructure resources that we created
from here we can see overall health we
can go ahead and inspect our clusters
and drill down into individual clusters
and then head over to Cobra ATS engine
or we can see more details drilling down
into physical nodes or we can see the
pods that are scheduled on them or take
a look at the actual workloads where we
can see everything running across all
notes and namespaces or a specific
namespace like the one for the
application
[Music]
now let's take a look at the web
front-end services and ingress show us a
list of all the services with Network
endpoints let's filter on sto ingress
gateway which is the name of the
services hosting the endpoints for our
applications front-end click on one of
these for either of our clusters ingress
manages inbound traffic to our
application and we can see what that
looks like by clicking on the expose
endpoint looks like the application is
working
let's switch view now this web
application is made up of a number of
communicating micro services so let's
see how things look from the internal
traffic perspective of anthos service
mesh I get the anthos dashboard let's
inspect services managed by the service
mesh we've got two views available the
default table view and a topology view
these years provide a great deal of
information without having to write any
custom monitoring code whatsoever
the table view presents us with
essential service metrics like error
rate and percentile latency while the
topology view presents us with a graph
visualization of our workloads and
services from either view we have a way
to drill down into a detailed page for
any service as we can see here using the
shipping service in this service detail
view you can see telemetry details that
provide an overview of the shipping
services performance if we use the left
nav and click connect to services we can
see inbound and outbound connections for
our shipping service we can even note
that traffic over these connections is
unencrypted by looking at the lock icons
from these pages we're able to inspect
service mesh details but what happens
when there's an issue let's check out
the monitoring built into anthro service
mesh at the table view we can see a
summary at the top of the services were
monitoring with the service level
objective or SLO right now it looks like
none are being monitored for performance
so let's fix that well click into the
shopping cart service to create an SLO
using latency as our indicator of
performance and choosing a very low
threshold like 5 milliseconds with a
goal of 90% compliance or a one-day
rolling period
this will let us see an example of what
it looks like when we have service
performance that exceeds our daily error
budget after we submit this s low we can
easily see it in the health panel let's
go back to our services table we can see
that we've now upgraded to have only 10
services without s ellos for the
shipping car service with an SLO we can
see that our intentionally aggressive
objective has put us past our error
budget now let's look at how to better
secure our service traffic as an
e-commerce application data security is
critical to our enterprise and customers
we need to ensure our services are only
using encrypted traffic but recall that
we noticed earlier our shipping service
had an open lock revealing that
unencrypted traffic can pass through
anthesis easily fix this with an
encryption policy applying through
configuration so we don't even have to
touch the service code ass activate
cloud shell so we can make some changes
to configuration to be able to access
our project to make changes from the
cloud shell environment we'll need to
ensure that we have a few tools
installed we'll be using cube control a
clone of our configuration repository to
synchronize our changes and the cube
config environment for our project well
source an initialization script into our
shell environment that takes care of all
of this for us
so we're ready to go
once this is all done let's set to the
config repo clone directory then let's
use the integrated editor to quickly
edit our mesh policy so we can tighten
up our restrictions by getting rid of
permissive mode and by requiring mutual
TLS for all matching house after we make
these configuration changes will run no
most FET to ensure there aren't any
other issues once we push our changes to
the upstream repository with git Anthes
config management will quickly detect
and apply the changes to our clusters
will run a little function helper to go
ahead and watch for those changes here
and that's how easy it is to apply a
policy and have anthos config management
synchronize it across all the clusters
in your environment finally we can
return to the connected services view
and after enough time passes for the
desired time span we can visually
confirm that we only have MPLS traffic
with the green locks four connected
services there are plenty of examples of
security guard rails you can set to
protect your application environment
with anthos start with a tutorial and
check out the docs to learn more we've
just taken a short tour of anthos using
a sample deployment this is just a taste
of things for you to try so check out
our tutorial launch a sample deployment
and explore anthos for yourself
[Music]